hello everyone and welcome back to the
TCC the top chess engine competition
this is a super finals a hundred games
match between blue hs0 in stockfish and
we have covered a few games from this
event feel free to check them out if you
haven't and while we were busy enjoying
our kappa blanka saga
stock which equalized the in score and
this is no game 86 so after 85 games the
score is a tie in the previous game
stockfish played with the white pieces
in this exact same line as you all know
the openings are predefined so first
Lila will have a certain opening with
the white pieces then stock which has
the exact same opening with the white
pieces to see how each of them affairs
in different openings and it's a very
interesting game I'm sure you'll enjoy
this it features one of the most
exciting lines of the of the Kings
Indian Samish and well without further
ado let's just check it out
Lilith has the white pieces as we've
said we have d4 Knight to f6 c4 g6
Knight to c3 and as we already mentioned
the Kings Indian defense is on the board
we have E for d6 the this is the
standard line f3 the semi variation now
we have castles Bishop to e3 and now II
five we have d5 by white grabbing more
space in the center and now Knight to h5
preparing f5 but also in some lines
preparing this Queen to h4 check Queen
to d2 and now this is one of those lines
where we do have Queen to h4 checked and
this line has been played in many times
between human players as well and black
a white has several options here QD 1 is
an option Bishop to have 2 blocking is
an option then the Queen will just
retreat but the bishop will be somewhat
misplaced here there will be no bushel
to h6 ideas with exchanging of the dark
square Bishop so g3 this is has all been
pre predefined Knight captures and g3
and of course you cannot capture because
you lose the rook on h1 but Queen to
have 2 and now you could try something
like Knight f5 so the knight would
defend the Queen and h4 but wise would
simply kiss or another white would
simply capture the knight ni5 and white
would be up a piece so here white black
actually captures two pieces and 2 point
for a queen with night captures on f1
Queen captures on h4 and night captures
on e3 so grabbing both of the bishops
and here we have King - II - I'm making
room for this rook to come into the game
also the Queen can now retreat we are
Queen - you won but also it pushes the
knight back we have Knight captures on
c4 and now again this exact same
position has been reached numerous times
between human players and here in Knight
to h3 was the main move and this is
exactly what stockfish played when
stockfish had the white pieces in this
line against Leela and then the game
continued Knight characteris room d1 and
so on and so on and stock wish drew that
game were stockfish had the white pieces
against Lille at chess zero here after
Knight captures on c4 and Leela doesn't
go for this line that is mostly Lagos
Queen tae-hwan and this is a new move in
this position already on move 13 so
let's see how how this unwinds we have
f5 buy stock fish h4 now by Aaliyah and
now F captures on e4 now with Knight
captures on e4 and c6 now seems like
weakening of the d6 pawn but for the
moment you cannot take advantage of
it'll be for example b3 you want to keep
the defender of the d6 pawn but black
will not move it but you just capture
here and you still cannot capture deny
defense captures captures and here black
would just be better pawn captures
Bishop g4 black will get some very nice
development night is coming to c6 to d4
the other Brook is coming into the game
as well so black will just be just be
better here so after c6 we have Queen to
d1 now perhaps if this is captured in
the knight escape the way the Queen will
also be eyeing the d6 pawn and also
Queen to b3 might not be a bad
opportunity for the Queen to go - we
have Bishop to d7 and now not
immediately going for this like we
mentioned because Knight captures and B
three runs in tonight d4 check which
simply delivers check and blocks the
Queen's attack towards the d6 pawn so
here first King King to f2 by Lola now
comes Bishop to f5 and now Knight g3
night-cap person b2 attacks the Queen
Queen b3 attacks than both night and the
b6 pawn but stockfish has everything
calculated as the bishop gars d3 first
93 check kingi - and now comes Knight to
c5 attacking the Queen watt also
defending the b7 pawn queen back to d1
and now Bishop back to D seven black
wants to keep an eye on this pawn if
white ever does capture here black wants
this Bishop to be under stab you know
slicing all the way to g2 and here yeah
okay if you play this then like we said
there will simply be too much pressure
along along this line even if the Queen
captures is there still night here the
the night is coming into the game for
example Ruby one now efore busting open
this little bit of King's defenses
that's left F captures Knight captures
you Knight captures Bishop captures with
check attacks the rook King h2 and now
rook 88 will be simply too much for for
whites the handle Bishop to e5 is the
idea of winning the Queen but even if
the Queen moves this check will be
devastating and so on and so on black
would be winning here so here's there's
no time to go for this d6 we can see @
h5 viola
I will night beat the a6 now finally
making room for this rook to enter the
game rook the c1 and now rook to f6
instead of just ringy dropping into the
game we have the idea of doubling rocks
along the EDF file which makes sense
with Knight 1 to e 2 and now rook 8 f8
stopped with doubles on the F file and
now you have to defend the f3 pawn so
first h6 kicking the bishop back and now
the rook is no longer needed on h1 or
row 2 F 1 we have g5 by stockfish and
now King to g1 and here rook captures on
h6 grabbing that pawn Knight to e4 and
now rook to f7 we have Knights do to c3
and here we have rook to g6 we have d
capers on c6 finally Bishop captures on
c6 and not rook to c2 with Bishop to g7
and now look to d2 now putting pressure
against the d6 pawn so Bishop to f8 now
the bishop helps out but doesn't really
matter allele and now finally grabs it
Knight captures on d6 and now rook to f4
with the ideas of Bishop to a4 at
acting the queen we have night Stewie
two attacking the rook but now first and
in between move Bishop to a for
attacking the Queen and Queen e1 and
here finally Bishop captures on d6
Knight captures here and G captures on
a4 width check King to h1 and now comes
Bishop to c7 the bishop is no longer a
target but also covers the d8 and e6
square and the knight cover c7 so there
are no possible rook lists here and here
we have look - look - H - Ally last idea
is something like maybe Queen to h4 with
some with some pressure along the H file
and stock which of course has the bishop
pair which is the most important part
when this Bishop finally lands back on
c6 it will be an incredible piece and on
the other hand Laval doesn't really have
all that many pawns f3 is gonna fall
soon and then after Leela places all of
after stockfish places all of the pieces
to the optimal squares you're not you
don't really have anything to keep them
away from those squares we have Knight
to d7
rook to g1 and now comes Bishop finally
to c6 you know taking over this diagonal
rook captures on g 6h captures and now
yes you do want to prevent the f3 pawn
for me in capture but you also don't
want to waste time if you can get the
Queen to h4 and maybe get the Queen up
there then maybe White has something so
Leela went for Queen to h4 immediately
but let's see what happens if you first
try something like rook to h3 defend the
f3 pawn and only then go Queen h4 and
then try to create some sort of an
attack then you get E for and black is
just too fast Queen to h4 now comes he
captures on f3 with the threat of f2
discovered to check from the bishop
Queen h8 check Oh black will have to
allow a couple of checks king f7
rope to h7 check came to e6 and now
comes the Queen to GA check and now
Queen to King to f6 rook to f7 check
King g5 and now there are no more checks
here no more useful checks here well at
least so here white would have to go for
recapture Sun d7 hoping for Bishop
captures and Queen here check
but white/black would just ignore white
f2 check now there's no way to start a
stop the promotion f1 is coming so you
would have to block with Czech Bishop to
e5 now blocking this check but also not
allowing the rook to capture it because
the rook is pinned
kingi to now finally the King can
prevent the pond from queening but now
just night before attacks the rook and
black it will be just up too much
material for example Queen d8 chair to
Google kingi for Queen ch-check will go
king gage for Queen h3 check King g5 and
now finally you will have to capture the
pawn here but after Knight captures you
you just have a bishop a bishop and the
night against the Queen and the black is
up three points this will be completely
winning for black so there is in fact no
time for roof to h3 a preparation move
before Queen to h4 so Leela goes Queen
to h4 immediately allows Bishop captures
an f3 we have King g1 and now Bishop to
b6 check King has to go to f1 and now
comes Bishop to h5 the bishop now also
prevents any counter play Oliva might
have had in mind Queen to e7 attacking
the knight here but now comes Knight to
see finally the knight returns from the
edge of the board and defends his you
know colleague rook to f2 and then now
comes Knight to f8 we have Queen
captures on e5 stockfish gives up one
one point here to activate it tonight on
better squares with Knight f2 e6 we have
a 4 here and now comes Bishop to c7
attacking the Queen Queen d5 and now
comes Bishop to g4 and now it's pretty
much clear what stockfish is doing as
what which will want to push f3 at some
point get that Bishop all the way to g3
and deliver the final blow Bishop to h3
so we look the c2 now with ideas of rook
captures alia would be very much
interested in giving up this rook for
two nights
but first the bishop to h3 check King e2
and now comes b6 of course defending the
knight on c5 Queen a8 check we have King
to f7 and now Queen characters on a 7
and now just came to f6 I'm pinning and
also you
to bring the king as close as possible
to where all the action is we have a
five here a very nice idea as now if
pawn captures them again rook captures
on c5 becomes a possibility but we have
Bishop to f5 check attacking the net
check it's just Bishop to a5 attacking
the rook and now if the rook moves just
be captures on a5 will be very nice as
the rope is no longer on the C file so
here we have rook captures in c5 Leela
finally goes for this you cannot capture
with the night you have to capture with
the pawn because the bishop would be
lost so here now we have B captures on
c5 okay at least now Lila has a very
nice pass pawn but now Queen - Queen -
eight
we have Bishop to g4 check King to f1
and now comes f3 and now you see what
stockfish has accomplished the idea is
Bishop to g3 followed by Bishop to h3
and it's all over here we have Quinta h8
check by Lola and now it's a very nice
check because if King to have five then
Lila has enough resources to draw this
game if King gave 5 then a6
Bishop to g3 not preparing mushroom to
h3 but ok you cannot do it while the
Queen is still here so a seven Knights
to c7 and then out comes a eight Queen
and now after Knight captures you don't
want to capture the night because you
can allow can't allow - rotation to
recheck but Queen to see it check will
allow Lee lat deliver up you know
continuously start delivering a
perpetual for example King g5 you could
go Queen d8 check King h5 you go Queen
h8 checking here Queen can go back when
d8 check King f5 and just continue
checking Queen f8 the King can never
come to f4 because here you would just
deliver Queen B a check and pick up the
bishop on g3 then black no longer has an
attack if you go to a light square then
the knight is picked off with check and
the white continues just checking
so a very nice check Queen to h8 check
but stockfish does not have problem
calculating all the lines so King g5
instead of f5 and now the the same idea
no longer applies we have a 6 by Leela
similar but not quite the same
Bishop to g3 now stockfish plan is not
the shop h3 but
hmm sorry about that going about it from
the other side Bishop f5 to d3 check we
have a seven now comes Bishop to f5 and
here you don't have time to bring the
Queen into the game because of Bishop to
d3 this is check g1f to check not gonna
skin g2 and now Queen to f1 check you
will capture Queen f4 check and after
the King moves that there should be four
pics of the Queen and black will be left
up two points and end the piece a
completely winning endgame for black
so after this Bishop to a5 we have Queen
- h1 by Leela but it doesn't help Bishop
to d3 check by stockfish with King to g1
and not Knight d4 again if you bring a
queen into the game then you get to this
beautiful beautiful checkmate 92 check
King f1 and now comes Knight f4 other
discovered check from the bishop on d3
also the bishop is covering a 1 you
would have to move back and now f2 is
checkmate and look at this White has two
queens and sorry about that
White has two queens and black is just
you know so so so I saw oft played white
with with the two bishops tonight and
the pawn the deliver checkmate
I might even use this as a thumbnail so
after night the d4 we have Queen - H -
hoola now offers a queen but there's
very little point to it covering in the
92 check but stockfish doesn't care
Bishop captures we have King to have two
now blocking the pawn and now comes King
to f4 and here we'll just play the Queen
to e1 and both the Lila and stockfish
agree that there was no more no more
point in playing this game
that's a devaluation is just too great
in in sawfish favor but again if you
bring a queen into the game it's a it's
a similar idea bishop g3 check King g 1f
to check King g2 and now comes Queen to
a pawn to a phone Queen and this is not
checkmate
yeah I'll move 64 very interesting
that's a very nice number in the chess
world allele at chess a zero resigned
the game and stockfish is now on game 86
at one point in the lead so Lula has 14
more games to equalize at least equal at
this match if not you
planning to win it so it will be intense
all the way and it's very interesting
will now this this line 'if I've you
know Queen h4 check maybe this become
popular now with the black pieces as
stock which has defeated Leela with the
black pieces and stop and Leela was able
to draw the game against stock fish with
the black pieces here so it seems like a
black can either win or draw here never
lose and but it's interesting in the
database when humans play this humans
mostly win would white here so I guess
you know humans just aren't all that all
that great in positions like these but
yeah you know it might give it give the
line some new wind we'll see what
happens I don't think so but you never
know
last yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Walid
al body Lois bonnet Anton baklanov
Weasley Santos and the Joseph
compression for a contribution to my
channel thanks a lot I really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon
most likely continuing the capablanca
saga I think I will definitely upload
one more game today from the 19:14 son
Peter Berg a tournament thank you all
and I'll see you soon